i've heard black men say that when it  comes to  being with a black woman it's as if they  have to be on all the time and have to  still prove themselves they don't want  to have to do that and so they typically  go for  women that they don't have to  like prove themselves to and that  obviously is not true for everybody but  it's one that one thing that i  have experienced and to believe like  there is a standard that black women  have that subconsciously we don't know  about that we hold our black men too and  when they don't  meet those standards it's like oh you're  no good you're  just all like all these other dudes out  here it's hard for them to be held to a  standard that's not them and not to be  given a chance to be themselves they  feel like they have to be this image all  the time at work of out in the streets  when they're with their friends family  whatever it's like when they come home  to their significant other they want to  be able to relax everything and so